this $21 sweater from a mall favorite
fashion store it turned out to be such a
thing created one of the Oscars most
talked-about red-carpet ensembles ever
and only et has the story behind Sharon
Stone's infamous who are you wearing
moment straight from Sharon herself what
it's Sunday and can I wear this
in the mid-90s no one was more famous
than Sharon Stone could I change into
something more appropriate but in 1995
she ascended to a whole new level of
stardom that's when she started opposite
Robert De Niro in Martin Scorsese's Las
Vegas epic casino her performance
received universal acclaim from critics
which led to awards recognition there
was no surprise when Sharon took home a
Golden Globe Award or only she received
an Academy Award nomination for Best
Supporting Actress but it was her
wardrobe on Oscar night that no one saw
coming
she arrived in a Valentino skirt paired
with actually let's just have Sharon
tell you herself
you heard correctly
surrounded by designer gowns that cost
thousands Sharon donned a turtleneck
from the gap priced at just 21 dollars
from fashion experts to viewers at home
people were obsessed with Sharon's
casual glam look the gap has been a
go-to destination for fashion basics
since 1969 but by the 90s they had
forged a pop culture identity defined by
Hollywood themed ad campaigns and became
a staple in shopping malls around the
world but no one was more shocked than
the execs at Gap when one of their
products appeared in the sea of red
carpet glamour shocked I mean it's
always about designers at the Oscars and
now it's about the gap so that was very
flattering for our company yeah you
could say the brand's employees were
pretty excited to hear the news so we
received a phone call late Monday night
and she said that she had all these
designers approaching her but she just
wanted to be comfortable and wear
something in her own closet this is our
mock style turtleneck short sleeve very
popular for us it's a great basic for
every for the collection I'm not a
shopper no and the following month
Sharon gave et the story of how it all
came together you know it turned out to
be such a thing
such a thing such a thing you know you
get so neurotic because you want to have
the right dress right and then when you
don't it's like now what
right and I called my friend Ella Mirage
Nick who done the costumes on Basic
Instinct like I'm thinking about wearing
this t-shirt and the skirt the next
thing I know Ellen's at my house was
like what it's Sunday and can I wear
this you need a jacket let's get in the
closet and we just you know it started
out just so innocently and it became
became like a thing a thing that Sharon
didn't mind apparently because two years
later she wore the gap again to the
Academy Awards but you know what it was
kind of cool it was good kind of rocked
the fashion world I think a little
absolutely Sharon had no idea how right
she was
Sharon charcoal turtleneck is too
frequently cited as the moment the gap
reached peak success her straight from
the closet looks set enough shockwaves
that people are still talking about it
over 20 years later and it proved a
celebrity Styles can make anyone
reexamine how they think about fashion
scratch that almost everyone you know
would be a very sad world is if it all
we wanted was everything and this is not
knocking the gap the gap is great but is
everything turned into the gap
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]